richard such a weirdo he he behaves like
a six-year-old halloween started already
for you right oh yeah in August in
August in August in May as soon as it's
a hundred days to Halloween that's when
it is crunch time yeah and what do you
mean that that Halloween begins on like
September first or August like in other
words 100-day that's when I saw wearing
orange it's so weird
I like being weird will was telling me
he takes the train every day was Richard
into work oh he does I'm Richard I can't
hear so good so he blasts his headphones
and he listens to Halloween screaming
like sound effects of people screaming
yeah I got rushed on the quiet car the
other day yeah yeah I didn't realize why
would you I mean for the life of me I
can accept other people's differences
but why would you listen to screaming
just screaming just screaming well
that's part of it it's not all screaming
but there's sections of screaming in it
you know it's like laboratory sounds and
and monsters burping and eating and then
there's women screaming in it I love it
I love I I go on YouTube and get these
old Halloween cassettes from like I know
you're not that's like not something
you're doing in front of other people
like you're just you're actually into it
I love it brings back so many great
memories for me there's people screaming
well yeah yeah brings back great
memories well of listening to those
tapes when I was a kid yeah but I mean
but you're not a kid anymore you're like
I feel like a kid you're like 40 how old
you 45 - 45 yeah will tells me on the
train like you're sitting there reading
horror magazines horror hound Andrew
morgue and thank Oriya decapitations and
dismemberment Weekly and I look over
there's like decomposed people that he's
like on this magazine and then the cover
this morning is like the Church of Satan
versus The Satanic temple and I like it
like that it's my favorite it's right I
mean it's
not even that he reads I hope the sounds
that Richard listens to cannibal eating
a person now is sitting on the train it
reminds me of callous shell spook yard
back in Kansas I used to go to as a kid
woman screaming while tortured you got
that on the headphone that's the one who
was playing on the train people yeah
people do not [ __ ] around with the quad
I got sure yeah that is this good I mean
I'm like I like sound effects when
they're mixed in with a bit it reminds
me of Halloween and being a kid no I
read to this yeah but it's funny the the
train will and I ride on there's this
big like mean-looking guy that's just is
everybody and he's just made the poor
and scared the [ __ ] on maniacal laughing
and cuckoo clock your favorite
Wow that's that's a classic their
hour-long train now I have to I stopped
sitting in the quiet car so don't yell
there oh my god that would make me
insane I am and call me crazy I would
listen to music maybe maybe